[Musica]
va beh
estate che ho giocato talmente tanto
happy vis che questa cazzo di canzone
mela sognerò anche 80 anni anche quando
avrò smesso di giocarci da secoli viene
da tutti ragazzi e prevenuto synthes
nuovo video io sono fari j
oggi so che dovevo uscire ieri ragazzi
ma è uscito oggi lo so che la gente è
venuta sotto casa mia qui forconi potete
andare via andiamo con pil simpson rock
swing ragazzi allora fatemi capire una
cosa che non fermatevi non ho che conta
alla rovescia
ma che cazzo fai perché ci homer perché
ciò perché si fa le pippe davanti a
tutti cazzo che figata rica come fattore
homer così io invece sì invece si mese
si madonna che testata la birra la cosa
stranissima li sta roba è che ho fatto
c'è la birra è uguale alla duff ce ne
vuole credetemi la madonna che salto
fatto guarda come si casa si merda sì
che culo i palloni che cosa c'entra con
i simpson non ho capito lei era tutto in
tema simpson ragazzi compreso lo sfondo
tranne i palloni che mai capito che
cazzo servono ma vabbè da uno che si
chiama steam cook ed potato non potevo
aspettarmi di meglio ragazza machine gun
facciamo questo che mi sembra più figo
ancora questa rosa ma basta mi sta
indicando quale l'arma zio ma grazie
guardano lavori ca vista sei proprio un
gentile zio grazie mille di avermelo
detto ma se queste sedute mattutine
accesso quanto sono noiose con la quanto
ho pagato eccome
complimenti per i livelli zio anche tu
ci stai dentro in passivo in passi ball
jump non imposti con impasti voglio dire
che è impossibile
sì è proprio impossibile cazzo stavo
vincendo così raga piano piano
no che gol non ha detto straw allora
senti sì ho preso la palla e non sarà un
cazzo perché così guarda lo vedi il
cursore seguì il corso by ok ok bravo
bravo
ha funzionato per un centesimo di
secondo in meno facevo 666 però ha
funzionato walking sguardo strava
protesta che bellezza
[Musica]
ma è bellissimo
l'estate secondo ex ragazzi il geniale
attivate una mano alla cittadina l'altra
ma nella cittadina un movimento peso
hanno preso e non lo manco preso una
manager spadina una ecco adesso preso
file un movimento sexy e bellissima gara
come si sta divertendo non lo schalke è
bello contento come ho fatto a non
giocare a sta roba prima voglio saperlo
bomba eccolo lì il taglio di capelli c'è
stato grazie e basta
blame trower a madonna lanciafiamme
cos'è ma x c'è la cosa più strana visto
livello non è tanto il fatto che ci sia
un pelato che usi delle armi per
chiedervi che a gargano pagano in tempo
ciarlo stiamo quale ci mangiamo un mese
con quello affumicato credit event
whitby cosa ai long e va bene come ma
passa che non cambia e alcuni prima che
ha fatto suo livello tra l'altro sembra
che una debolezza per la merda proprio
un milione per cento imposti dai ragazzi
ma tanto ormai ci siete ragazzi posso
fare ciò il cazzo duro che mancavano
arriva sì in cura da sola la venia
questa ma [ __ ] dai fammi vincere
bastardo
[Musica]
o yo yo yo yo yo ma ci hai capito un
cazzo
proprio in prossimo facciamo questo va
che mi sembra più più isis andiamo
avanti
bello questo è carino è un caso ma non
posso andare direttamente sotto e
prendere le monete si piano piano ma sei
serio non è possibile che prima è la
vera mentana roma indecente che cazzo
stai parlando è stato salvime e 10 6 con
devo sopravvivere 10 se va bene ma forse
no non è così semplice come credevo
raccattato la fermi un attimo calmi tua
mamma l'ho vista così un giorno non
molto lontano
ho vinto a mero vivo erano ancora vivo
ragazzi perché non lo sapevo va bene
sempre più figo segue il socio sembra
carino era chiusa lurido stronzo di
merda che sarebbe tipo calcio con i
seguenti zone ronaldo ancora lui titoli
b e colpo di testa si ingrossa la palla
ronaldo c'è tornando cade ci pensa al
suo culo cazzo fai vabbè ma fallo
arbitro cazzo sta a sviluppare che è
stronzo in quella madonna ma [ __ ]
quasi ancora di ronaldo incredibile di
testa di cazzo non fa che può anche gigi
gigi c'è ressa che cazzo o ai lori
domani ecco con le mani ma non ci credo
che parata
imparate assurda dai dai
mica che il cazzo è lebron james la mia
tra pro funziona no non ci credo come ho
fatto devi morire di testa non a dio e
c'è e c'è e su camelo su canon con la
mia mano con la tua marco sai usare
mi dispiace ragazzi ma non lo rifaccio
mai nella vita questa la chiosa ragazzi
facciamo un paio di miei livelli come al
solito prima del finale fa vj attenzione
riggi scalatore fa visita all
ma cos'è
ma no però quasi arrivato casa vj per
favore va bene per favore cosa fai
questo livello non è tanto difficile per
chi xk è non mi sono impegnato ma poi
per favore fai questo livello grazie
mille da andrea morandi caro andrea
spero che tu come morandi non ti mangi
da me era simile francesi stai facendo
questo livello non sarà una cosa ante
difficile perché è tardi e sono stanco
va bene prendi una bella rincorsa che un
quale gamma dei quali gambe zio che c'è
il po
io corro così sono unito b boy io ho
vinto la vita per me direi di fare
l'ultimo ragazzi che mi fa più paura di
tutti che fa vj quiz quante volte ha
giocato è più vista aggiornato il 18 6
2000 e che cazzo non sono io sarà il 18
64 2014 39 a caso [ __ ] era 41 41
va bene questa una sanità impossibile
saperlo fa vj e mitico no dovevo andare
su no ma franco era ecco un po di
momenti epici tifo dj dammi rapirla
donna dammi la donna avir bellissimo
viva la nutella no aviv la patata questa
è una patata viva farisei certo che
bello quanto e canne fumi al giorno
fammi capire caro ragazzo va bene e nico
20 treni cose il vincitore david di oggi
comunque ragazzi con coloro episodio
perché sono rimasto abbastanza
sbalordito dall ultimo livello grazie
per questi livelli che mi cambia la
giornata ogni volta che i ragazzi con
come episodio spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto è come se i ragazzi se vi è
piaciuto allenamento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e cavani video tra
tedeschi siano però mi piace a vito una
patata in più che fa sempre comodo se se
non si disegna civica prossima vita
le ragazze
data la fatina peso lo prendo che non
hanno compreso oramai dalla patina ora è
4 bei nomi di movimento 7